Hugo est-ce que vous pensez qu'on pourra
dire un jour dans un monde où tout le
monde sera végétarien comme vous ou
vegan non non je pense pas je pense que
c'est un peu illusoire de penser ça
parce que je dis dans le livre c'est pas
il faut tous devenir végétarien ou vegan
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut réduire
notre consommation de produits animaux
parce que non seulement ça détruit les
écosystèmes dont on dépend de nous pour
survivre mais on inflige aussi une
violence qui est pas nécessaire aux
animaux et j'essaie d'expliquer que le
monde dans lequel on vit est violent le
rapport entre un prédateur et une proie
c'est un prêt c'est un rapport violent
donc l'idée c'est pas d'aller vers un
monde sans violence c'est de limiter la
violence à celle qui est indispensable
et ce qu'on fait nous aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on inflige des violences aux animaux
dont on peut se passer la corrida
torturé un taureau pour s'amuser ça sert
à rien pour survivre chasser des espèces
qui sont en déclin ça ne sert à rien en
plus la plupart sont pas manger personne
mange du renard personne mange du
blaireau alors celle-là sont pas en
déclin mais il y en a d'autres qui le
sont
indispensable non c'est pas
indispensable bon moi je mange plus de
viande depuis six ans je me sens
je me sens pas plus mal on peut être en
bonne santé sans en manger on peut être
en bonne santé en en mangeant c'est bien
de dire ça mais mais
c'est de réduire cet élevage intensif
est-ce que vous savez combien on a bats
d'animaux chaque jour en France juste en
France 5 millions 3 millions 3 millions
par jour ça fait à peu près un milliard
par an et juste pour la France on mange
beaucoup trop de viande par rapport à ce
dont on a besoin et donc ce qu'il faut
faire c'est tous ensemble qu'il y ait
des millions de personnes qui réduisent
de manière importante leur consommation
c'est plus efficace que d'avoir quelques
milliers de gens qui sont parfaits vegan
ou végétariens il faut qu'on soit
nombreux à faire ça bon clément tu avais
une question pour eux oui j'avais une
question Hugo au début de votre essai
vous expliquer que les gorilles qui sont
dans la forêt de de Wendy et qui
n'aiment pas voir les êtres humains car
ils préfèrent rester seul c'est 650
euros l'heure et lorsque vous allez les
voir vous allez les premiers blancs qui
vont les approcher vous ne savez pas
comment ils vont réagir et
éventuellement s'il réagissent s'il
charge il y a des fusils d'assaut qui
forcément vont les tuer donc ma question
c'est pour un défenseur comme goût de la
cause animale quel est l'objectif en
fait de les mettre en danger alors c'est
un peu plus compliqué
[Applaudissements]
parce que on voit que c'est le seul gars
qui a bossé autour de moi
[Applaudissements]
la ligne gâteau
il a dit à quatre pattes ouais bien sûr
le mille-patte il a pas vraiment ouais
et là tu as voulu dans votre livre que
les gorille du Botswana
le gars on voit on dirait que c'est un
gars qui est venu d'une autre émission
oui il est très rond là il était le nom
là à côté non
c'est incroyable bravo pour répondre en
fait la la forêt dont on parle c'est la
forêt impénétrable de buildis en Ouganda
c'est comme ça et en fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une forêt où il y a 500 gorilles
de montagne qui vivent c'est à peu près
la moitié de la population mondiale il
reste que 1000 gorilles de montagne et
ils ont réussi à sauver cette forêt qui
est allé être complètement rasé pour
faire des plantations de thé en
autorisant certains touristes à aller
voir une partie des familles de gorille
il y a que certaines familles qui sont
accessibles et l'idée c'est que en
échange du prix que paye les touristes
on finance le salaire des Rangers on
donne un peu d'argent aux habitants et
ça ça fait qu'ils ont intérêt à pas
raser cette forêt donc c'est une manière
de protéger ses gorilles c'est un
équilibre plutôt intelligent qui a été
trouvé et il y a jamais eu de charges de
gorille qui ont nécessité de tirer sur
les gorilles et évidemment le but de
cette de ce reportage c'était d'aller
montrer cette solution qu'on trouvait
les ou demander à cet endroit pour
protéger la forêt parce que
malheureusement dans la plupart de ceux
des pays pauvres les forêts sont
complètement rasés pour mettre des
cultures à la place donc il faut trouver
un juste milieu entre laisser totalement
tranquille les animaux et trouver un
moyen d'avoir un petit peu de
financement pour les populations qui
protège la forêt alors
non delphine est la plus concernée quand
même moi je suis pas concerné par
l'écologie
formidable parce que effectivement comme
vous le dites il est vraiment mesuré et
donc du coup il séduit et les
végétariens et les véganes et les
personnes qui ont le droit d'attention
et absolument tout le monde donc pour ça
Hugo merci parce que pour moi tu es la
voix pour les enfants la plus belle
c'est toi qui t'a changé des choses
parce que c'est pas de l'écologie
punitive en fait vous nous
montre pas
là les trois là c'est on perd 150 mités
spectateurs par minute on comprend
pourquoi quand on les connaît on
comprend pourquoi vous n'êtes pas là
voilà si on déconner Gilles Verdez dit
l'heure vous êtes nuls les gars
regardez-les regardez dans le bas elle
sera avec eux
sans déconner
c'est un truc de fou
[Applaudissements]
bouillon de Pride
ouais c'est pas l'écologie plus petit
mais vas-y mais c'est quoi ça sans
déconner